oreille absolue c'est quelque chose qui
fascine ça fascine tellement le monde
l'aurait absolue c'est le fait
d'associer un auteur anonyme sans indice
à embarquer notre frère yvon dire c'est
un 12 qu'un seul tapha guèye est ainsi
bémol vous pouvez tout mélanger c'est
pas grave c'est automatique
vous l'avez l'oreille absolue l'un peu
perdu mais oui lui disons qu'on m'écoute
un peu mieux quand je dis que ça sert à
rien au coeur en tout cas ça peut être
un handicap
vous avez tous ces noms note qui vous
viennent spontanément dès que vous
écoutez quelque chose alors si vous
voulez chanter une chanson barça mais
c'est un peu embêtant parce que vous
aurez le nom note qui va interférer
quand vous lisez
oui la musique avec les paroles ça
interfère c'est parasitaire 8 en moyenne
ce qui n'empêche pas un gros handicap
mais c'est pour moi c'est une anomalie
que d'avoir un absolu
l'hypothèse actuelle qui est la plus
forte
c'est que c'est comme une tempe de
synesthésie il ya des collections qui
sont encore fonctionnels et qui aurait
pas dû être fonctionner qui aurait dû
disparaître avec le temps alors la
synesthésie fougeux définit ce que
voulait c'est le fait de voir pas
d'associer de code arbitraire par
exemple vous prenez le chiffre 4 9
points et leucate où vous voyez en jaune
et le neuf vous voyez en plus on va vous
pas me présenter les chiffres 84 et bien
il sera dans la même couleur
c'est des associations comme ceux qui
décollent mithra qui restent connus qui
reste collé et ça s'appelle une
sinestesia sable non seulement pour les
chiffrer à sa pole et l'étrennera pour
les saisons pour des tas de choses des
synapses interv au départ on en a
énormément
et puis chez le tout petit ça c'est là
qu'avec le temps alors ça correspond à
un peu près 10% des
musiciens occidentaux mais évidemment il
faut qu'ils soient exposés à au code il
faut avoir appris là il faut avoir
appris avant l'âge de 7 ans parmi les
certaines populations asiatiques en a
beaucoup plus ah oui oui ça peut monter
jusqu'à 50 book presque 50% à la moité
des musiciens qui ont qui développe
l'oreille absolue mais à plusieurs
interprétations et lui est ma préférée
c'est d'origine génétique mais parce
qu'ils sont exposés aux codes beaucoup
plus petit avec le seul facebook ou
multi qu'il y a une prédisposition
génétique et la doutre qui pense que
c'est lié au fait que ils ont une langue
tonale pourquoi ça fascine tant je pense
que la raison pour laquelle ça fascine
tout le monde se bat c'est rare